bonjour et merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur rt france c'était une promesse
de campagne d'interdire les les armes de
type militaire ça a été bien accueillie
par les par les canadiens qui utilisent
ces armes à feu oui donc ses armes à feu
sont ce type d'armes à feu est
disponible ici au canada ceci étant dit
c'est une petite minorité de gens qui
possèdent des armes à feu et une petite
minorité des gens qui possèdent ce type
d'armes le don qui veut il faut un
il faut comprendre que l'ensemble de la
population canadienne au taux de 70% de
la population canadienne est derrière le
premier ministre sur cette question là
de l'interdiction de ce type d'armes est
là et même pour ce qui est des armes de
poing ou si la population aux deux ter
est derrière lui une interdiction montre
resserrement des contrôles sur les armes
de poing aussi là ce sont ce sont des
armes que détiennent une partie de la
population vous l'avez dit les chasseurs
notamment mais que faire de sa va être
interdite d'ici à deux ans mais que
faire de ceux qui en possèdent donc pour
l'instant depuis hier en théorie ces
gens là n'ont pas le droit de circuler
avec leurs armes peuvent pas aller aux
champs tir par exemple pas là la chasse
ils ont pas le droit de les vendre
ils ont pas le droit d'en acheter de
nouvelles et donc autrement dit ces
armes à leur bon restées verrouillées
décharger à la maison c'est ce qu'il
doit faire ici deux ans donc la période
d' amnistie va prendre fin et d'ici là
le premier ministre et le parti libéral
j'imagine espère pour réussir à passer
une loi au parlement qui va leur
permettre de débloquer les fonds pour
racheter ces armes-là aux propriétaires
qui voudront les vendent
est ce que vraiment vous pensez que
interdire ce type d'armes résoudra le
problème des tueries apa le canada est
moins sujet à ses curés que les états
unis par exemple
effectivement on en a eu quand même
quelques unes dans les trente dernières
années de ses notamment il ya deux
semaines dans le mail écosse ceci étant
dit oui ce genre d'armé là est très
prisé par les tueurs de masse parce
qu'elles sont efficaces elle tire vite
elles sont faciles à recharger et elle
tire un calibre qui est bon
intermédiaire mais qui fait beaucoup de
dommages donc c'est pour ce qu'elles
sont utilisées et si on les retire des
circulations ces armes-là donc vont
coûter plus cher sur le marché noir ils
vont être plus difficiles à trouver un
vous savez les gens qui font des
massacres de masse même à la rigueur les
suicides dus si ce sont des actes
d'opportunités donc si on a à portée de
la main l'outil pour commettre le
massacre par exemple ben il ya beaucoup
plus de chances que la personne passe à
l'acte si elles doivent se le procurer
et surtout si le coût pour se procurer
cette armada donc est encore plus élevé
donc c'est un peu l'idée derrière cette
interdiction l'a fait découvrir chez les
libéraux mais aussi dans l'ensemble de
la communauté scientifique on on voit
que les l'offre facilite le passage à
l'acte vous parlez du marché noir et
d'augmentation du prix de ce genre
d'armes on peut s'en procurer néanmoins
et qu'elle par quel biais pas ses armes
sur le sol canadien
donc évidemment au contrairement par
exemple à la france nous sommes voisins
d'un des pays où est ce que le plus
d'armes à feu en circulation c'est très
facile de s'en procurer dans cours aux
états unis et une grande proportion des
armes à feu illégales se retrouvent sur
le marché canadien évidemment
proviennent du sud de la frontière et du
sud de la frontière donc nous avons tout
ce qu'on appelle communément des arènes
paris plein donc des pipelines des
lacets si vous préférez donc autrement
dit dédé des réseaux qui partent des
états unis et dans certains cas ils sont
aussi très facile de trouver la
provenance la plupart des césars bateaux
sont achetés légalement aux états unis
généralement on peut voir qu'ils sont
achetés sur des dents chez des
détaillants qui sont ceux qui se
trouvent sur le long des grands axes
autoroutiers américains dont par exemple
ici au québec
les armes sont souvent rien qui sont
retrouvés en provenance des états unis
proviennent souvent de l'autoroute 95
ans donc les yeux des trafiquants vont
aux états unis ciblent autoroute
achètent des armes sur le chemin et les
traverses à la frontière et le bain à la
frontière ils ont différentes façons de
le faire une de ses passions le qui
était identifiée par exemple à windsor
donc ce qu'on faisait c'est que les
trafics h cherchait des plaques
d'immatriculation canadienne donc à des
événements à détroit par exemple des
événements sportifs comme le hockey par
exemple et donc les insérer dans le pare
choc la voiture un détecteur gps et un
sac rempli d'armes à feu et les soyez
canadien retraverser la frontière sans
savoir qu'ils traversent
qu'il traversait des armes et une fois
de l'autre côté de la frontière 20 donc
ce qu'on fait si on utilise le gps pour
aller prendre les armes qui étaient
cachées sur la voiture donc vous voyez
ce sont deux genres c'est le genre de
moyens qu'on utilise la et d'une façon
générale les réseaux ici sont
relativement simple c'est pas comme pour
la drogue parce que ça prend beaucoup de
manutention et sécurité l'offre est
tellement grande aux états unis que
c'est relativement ça qu'il faisait et
du coup j'imagine que de l'autre côté de
la frontière il ya des mécontents on
connaît le puissant lobby des armes à
feu là bas comment ça se passe bon
évidemment aux états unis il regarde ce
qui se passe au canada et ils sont
horrifiés mais simplement ici des
groupes comme ici au québec par exemple
tout ce qu'on te registre des armes à
feu ou encore là le national forum
association qui est qui qui est partout
au pays ici évidemment et donc 10 accuse
le gouvernement d'utiliser la crise sur
la coved et donc la tuile dire quelques
semaines là pour faire avancer son plan
politique et faire plaisir à ses
supporteurs évidemment ils font ça ils
contestent la validité la définition de
ce qu'est une arme d'assaut de style
militaire donc ce que monsieur trudeau a
utilisé la commune dénomination pour
identifier certaines recettes d'armes
donc si c'est le genre de choses qu'on
voit ici on peut se fier au passé lors
des dernières réglementations sur les
armes à feu le lobby pro armes à feu
canadien a été très proactifs et donc
attaquer que ce soit en cours ou dans
les médias le gouvernement et a même
discrédité certaines des politiques
avaient été mises en place le notamment
la création d'un registre de toutes les
armes à feu ici au canada qui était
finalement abolie par le grand milan
consommateurs en 2012 merci beaucoup
françois hollande loin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france merci